Grazie a tutti
Basta
Grazie
Vabbè dai
No, no, no
Finito?
Allora
Invisibili
Punto interrogativo
L'avete letto, vero il titolo?
E voi capite bene che
Il titolo di questa lezione
È suggerito dal tema del festival
Di quest'anno, l'invisibile, certo
E la parte più importante
È il punto interrogativo
In altre parole
Vorrei dire molto chiaramente
Fin dall'inizio
Che le donne nel Medioevo
Non sono affatto
Invisibili
A meno che uno non pretenda
Di cercarle
Dove non le troverà
Perché come in qualunque
Altra epoca
Prima della nostra
Le donne
Non facevano direttamente
Politica
A meno che non fossero
Contesse
O regine
Perché in quel caso
La facevano
E nessuno diceva niente
Ma
Lasciamo stare
Le donne
Non facevano la guerra
E siccome
Molta cronachistica
Medievale
E anche
Molta storiografia
Nostra
Fino a poco tempo fa
Parlava soprattutto
Di politica
E di guerra
Vabbè
È chiaro che
Se uno si limita a quello
Le donne non le trova
E può sembrare
Che le donne
Nel passato
Non esistessero
Però io
Vorrei sottolineare
Che non è mica
Solo questione
Del Medioevo
Cercate un po'
Le donne
Nella storia
Della guerra
Del Peloponneso
Di Tucidide
Cercate un po'
Le donne
In una qualunque
Storia
Della seconda
Guerra mondiale
Che può avere
500 pagine
E non menzionare
Mai una donna
Quindi
Primo punto
Non è questione
Del Medioevo
Ma in altri
Tipi di fonti
Le donne
Le vedi
E come
Dove le vedi
Le vedi
Per esempio
Nei documenti notarili
Voglio dire
Negli atti
Che parlano
Di case
Di terra
Di compravendite
Di matrimoni
Di doti
Di eredità
E certo che le donne
Lì le vedi
E ancora di più
Le vedi
In quelle che noi
Del nostro mestiere
Chiamiamo
Le fonti narrative
I romanzi
Le novelle
Che descrivono
La realtà
Della vita quotidiana
E lì
Guarda un po'
Le donne
Sono metà
Dei personaggi
Perché nella vita
Reale
Le donne
Sono ed erano
Anche allora
Metà
Degli esseri
Umani
Che c'erano
In giro
E gli scrittori
Che come compito
Si davano
Non raccontare
La politica
O la guerra
Ma raccontare
La vita
Di tutti i giorni
E loro
Ovviamente
Le donne
Le vedevano
Esattamente
Come vedevano
I maschi
E però
Detto questo
Io giurerei
Che quando avete letto
Il titolo
Di questa lezione
Questo accostamento
Specifico
Fra medioevo
E invisibilità
Della donna
Giurerei
Che non vi ha stupiti
Più di tanto
Perché comunque
Corrisponde
A un luogo comune
Un luogo comune
Che rimbalza
Laddove
I luoghi comuni
Regnano
Sovrani
In tanti siti
Internet
Ma anche
In qualche libro
Di successo
Dove invece
Di analizzare
I modi
Complessi
In cui si manifesta
La disuguaglianza
Fra i sessi
Che non compare
Sempre
Nello stesso modo
In tutte le epoche
In tutte le situazioni
Ecco
Invece di analizzare
Questo
Magari si preferisce
Dire
Vabbè
La donna
Nel medioevo
Invisibile
Non c'era
Il medioevo
Era come
Certe società
Particolarmente
Arretrate
Misogene
Che vediamo
Anche oggi
Certe società
Di donne
Velate
Ecco
E così era
Il nostro medioevo
Allora
Vediamo cosa
Pensava
Un musulmano
Che nel medioevo
Ha conosciuto
I nostri antenati
Gli europei
Lui diceva
I franchi
Sapete che quando
Il mondo del Medio Oriente
I turchi
Gli arabi
Gli armeni
Sono venuti per la prima volta
A contatto con i nostri
E cioè al tempo
Della prima crociata
Li percepivano ancora
Come
I franchi
E sapete che
In tutte le lingue
Del Medio Oriente
E anche dell'Asia
Tuttora
Per dire
Un bianco
Un occidentale
Un europeo
Si usano sempre parole
Che hanno quelle radice lì
I frange
I frank
I franchi
Allora
Vediamo cosa pensava
Un musulmano
Dell'epoca delle crociate
Delle donne
Nel mondo
Dei franchi
Questo musulmano
È l'emiro di Cesarea
In Palestina
Usama
Ibn Munqid
Il quale
Dopo la prima crociata
Ha scritto un libro
Di memorie
In cui appunto
Racconta
Al suo pubblico
Un pubblico
Che legge
In arabo
Non tutti musulmani
Ci sono anche
Un sacco di cristiani
Fra quegli arabi
Di Palestina
Certo
C'erano allora
Come ci sono oggi
Allora molti di più
Però sono arabi
Vivono lì
All'improvviso
Sono arrivati
Questi barbari
Dall'occidente
A invaderli
Che gente sono
L'emiro
Usama
Ha da raccontare
Un sacco di cose strane
Su questa gente
Stranissima
Che è arrivata
A invadere la Palestina
Ma la cosa
Che lo colpisce
Di più
E ci torna
Più di una volta
E che non hanno
Nessuna gelosia
Delle loro donne
Le loro donne
Godono di una libertà
Assolutamente
Scandalosa
Vergognosa
E Usama dice
Cito
Virgolette
Presso i franchi
Non c'è ombra
Di senso
Dell'onore
E di gelosia
Se uno di loro
Va per la strada
Con sua moglie
E un altro
Lo incontra
Questi
L'altro
Prende per mano
La donna
E si tira
In disparte
Con lei
Per parlarle
Mentre il marito
Se ne sta
Da un lato
Aspettando
Che lei
Abbia finito
Di conversare
E se la fa
Troppo lunga
La lascia
Col suo interlocutore
E se ne va
Poi Usama
Anche
Diverse altre storie
Da raccontare
Ve ne cito
Solo una
Che è un po'
Più realistica
Delle altre
Gli era raccontata
Un bagnino
Cioè uno
Che teneva
Un bagno turco
In Palestina
Ci sono i bagni turchi
Chiaramente
Che sono poi
Le vecchie terme romane
Salvo che in occidente
La moda
Si era persa
Invece in Medio Oriente
C'è ancora
Arrivano i crociati
Dall'Europa
Scoprono
I bagni turchi
Fantastico
I clienti
Del bagnino
Sono spesso
Dei franchi
E lui
Ha raccontato
Una volta
Usama
Che una volta
È entrato
Nel bagno
Nelle terme
Un cavaliere
Dei franchi
E dice
Il bagnino
Sai che a loro
Quando vengono
Ai bagni
Gli piace
Stare nudi
Non come noi
Che teniamo
Il perizoma
Allora
Vengono nudi
Questo cavaliere
È entrato
Nudo
E siccome
Sono gente manesca
Per scherzo
Mi ha strappato
Il perizoma
Dice il bagnino
Ha visto
Che io mi ero
Rasato
Una raffinatezza
Mai vista
In Europa
Gli è piaciuto
Da matti
Ha detto
Fammelo anche a me
E io l'ho rasato
È il mio mestiere
L'ho rasato
E quando l'ho rasato
Il cavaliere
Mi ha detto
Magnifico
Fallo anche mia moglie
Ha chiamato
Sua moglie
E io l'ho rasata
Ora
Usama racconta
Questo per dire
Ma capite che gente
Sono questi
E quello che è affascinante
È la conclusione
Di questo principe
Arabo
Che con questa gente
Ha combattuto
Ha negoziato
Ha trattato
Ha combattuto
Di nuovo
E che non può
Capirli
Com'è possibile
Che fanno vedere
Le loro donne
Le lasciano andare
In giro
Le lasciano parlare
Con gli estranei
Non parliamo del bagnino
Ma insomma
Comunque
Non hanno nessuna gelosia
Quindi non hanno
Senso dell'onore
Dice il musulmano
Eppure al tempo stesso
Hanno tanto coraggio
Perché sui campi di battaglia
Gliel'hanno fatta vedere
E lui non riesce
A spiegarsela
Questa cosa
Dunque
Dunque agli occhi
Di un musulmano
Del dodicesimo secolo
Le donne degli europei
Altro che invisibili
Erano fin troppo visibili
Scandalosamente visibili
Detto questo
Se noi lasciamo perdere Usama
E confrontiamo quel mondo
Con il nostro
Ebbè no
Certo che le donne
Nel nostro medioevo
Si vedevano in giro
Meno
Degli uomini
Perché stavano a casa
Molto di più
Dei maschi
Ve lo dimostro
Avete presente?
Boccaccio
Sì
Il Decameron
Il prologo
Del Decameron
Nel prologo
Boccaccio dice
Io scrivo
Perché la gente
Possa distrarsi
Divertirsi
Dimenticare le preoccupazioni
E quindi scrivo
Soprattutto
Per le donne
Che hanno
Meno possibilità
Di sfogo
Rispetto agli uomini
E che sono
Più facilmente
Vittime
Della noia
O della depressione
Non dice la depressione
Boccaccio
Chiaramente
Ma intende
Quello
Perché Boccaccio
Dice
Voi lo vedete
Come vivono
Le nostre donne
Cito
Beh dice
Sto parlando
Delle donne
In generale
La ragazzina
Non ancora sposata
È certo
Ma anche
La donna sposata
Spesso
Ristrette
Dai voleri
Dai piaceri
Dai comandamenti
Dei padri
Delle madri
Dei fratelli
E dei mariti
Il più del tempo
Dice Boccaccio
Le donne
Dimorano
Racchiuse
Nel piccolo
Circuito
Delle loro
Camere
Stanno a casa
Perché il papà
E la mamma
La mamma anche
Non solo il papà
Il papà e la mamma
Non vogliono
Che la ragazzina
Esca
I fratelli
Non vogliono
Il marito
Non vuole
Che la moglie
Esca
E loro
Se ne stanno lì
Oziose
Quasi oziose
Sedute
In casa
E dice Boccaccio
E seco
Rivolgono
Si rigirano
In testa
Diversi
Pensieri
Li quali
Non è possibile
Che sempre
Siano allegri
E dice Boccaccio
E gli uomini
Ma gli uomini
Se hanno
Dei pensieri
Delle malinconie
Ma hanno
Mille modi
Per pensare
Ad altro
Loro vanno
In giro
Vedono
Parlano
Vanno a caccia
Vanno a pesca
Vanno a cavallo
Giocano
A soldi
Commerciano
E in questi modi
Allora possono
Gli uomo
L'uomo può dimenticarsi
In mille modi
I fastidi
I pensieri
La donna
No
Intendiamoci
La donna
Di cui parla
Il boccaccio
È
Virgolette
La donna
Del medioevo
Nemmeno per idea
È la donna
Di una grande città
Del trecento
La donna
Borghese
O aristocratica
Di una grande città
Della fine del medioevo
Non è che abbia
Molto in comune
Con una contadina
Dell'epoca
Di Carlo Magno
Con una longobarda
Dell'epoca
Delle invasioni
D'accordo
Il medioevo
Lungo
Lunghissimo
Infinito
Le cose cambiano
Continuamente
E anche
Nella sua città
Nel trecento
Ammettiamo che sia Firenze
Questa donna
Di cui parla
Boccaccio
Non è l'operaia
Non è
La mercantessa
La ragazza
Che vende al mercato
È la moglie
Di un uomo
Che conta
E che quindi
Vuole che lei
Se ne stia brava
A casa
E anche
Di questa donna
Che ha una condizione
Più elevata
E quindi
La paga
Non è che Boccaccio
Dica che non esce mai
E che non vede uomini
Però esce
Meno
Di quanto
Non facciano
Gli uomini
Ma perché dunque
Queste donne
Escono poco
Allora
Il fatto è
Innanzitutto
Che con buona pace
Dell'emiro
Usama
Anche se loro
Lo manifestavano
In modo meno
Ossessivo
Ma in realtà
Anche i nostri
Del medioevo
Avevano in testa
Questa idea
Di onore
E di un onore
Che rischia
Di essere messo
In pericolo
Da tante cose
Ma fra l'altro
Da come si comportano
Le mie donne
Non c'è dubbio
Che l'onore
Di un uomo
Dipende
Da come si comporta
Sua moglie
Sua figlia
Sua sorella
Certo
E quindi
Bisogna controllarla
Non c'è dubbio
Che la donna
È custodita
Guardata
Come dicono loro
Allora
A questo punto
Distinguiamo
La ragazza
Non ancora sposata
Bisogna fare attenzione
Perché non ci vuol niente
Rovinarla
Non ci vuol niente
Non deve andare
Troppo in giro
Non deve vedere
Troppa gente
Troppi uomini
Troppi ragazzi
Boccaccio ne racconta
Più di uno
Di questi casi
Nelle sue novelle
Magari non sono quelle
Che si leggono
Sempre a scuola
Ma andatela a cercare
Messer Lizio di Valbona
Vecchio signore
Che ha una figlia
Lui è vedovo
È una figlia unica
Lui è anziano
E quindi
A questa figlia
Ci tiene
Da pazzi
E quindi
La sorveglia
Lei era
Cito
Con maravigliosa
Diligenza
Guardata
Sorvegliata
Con estrema
Attenzione
Tant'è vero
Che lei stessa
Quando parla
Con un ragazzo
Che le piace
Gli dice
Tu vedi
Quanto io sia guardata
Però intanto
Parla con un ragazzo
Che le piace
Com'è che succede
Questa cosa
Ma perché in casa
Viene un sacco di gente
In casa vengono uomini
Questo ragazzo è un amico di famiglia
Messer Lizio
Lo considera quasi come un parente
E quindi entra in casa
In un ambiente sociale più modesto
Altra novella
Una novella straordinaria
Di Boccaccio
Ma straordinaria
Non perché sia una grande novella
Ma perché ci fa vedere quel mondo
Che non è spesso descritto
Il mondo della gente povera
Che nella Firenze del Trecento
Stava a casa
A lavorare
Operai e operaie
Che filavano
In casa
La protagonista
Della novella
È una ragazza
Da marito
La Simona
È figlia di operai
E di mestiere
Fila la lana
In casa
Come migliaia
Di donne povere
A Firenze
Che campavano
Faticosamente
Filando la lana
Per conto degli industriali
In casa
Dopodiché
C'è il garzone
Del padrone
Che porta il lavoro
A domicilio
E di conseguenza
Mi viene in mente
In questo preciso istante
Che ai miei tempi
Non so ancora adesso
Come dire
Amoreggiare
Si diceva filare
Non so se c'entri qualcosa
Certamente
La Simona
Che filava la lana
In casa
Quando arriva
Il ragazzo del padrone
Che porta la lana
Da filare
E beh
Due parole
Due sguardi
E insomma
Si capiscono
A questo punto
Lei vorrebbe uscire
Con il ragazzo
E con gli amici
E come si fa
Amica può dire al papà
Operaio
Papà esco col mio ragazzo
Apriti cielo
Però se gli dici
Una domenica pomeriggio
Sai oggi c'è la festa
Al monastero di San Gallo
È un pellegrinaggio
Ci vanno in tanti
È una famosa festa religiosa
A cui si va ovviamente
Sapendo benissimo tutti
Che si va per divertirsi
Per vedere gente
Per uscire di casa
Vado alla perdonanza
A San Gallo
Papà mi lasci uscire
Dice ma con chi vai?
Ah vado con una mia amica
Vabbè va
Vai
E la Simona
Con l'amica
Esce
Poi vanno ai giardini pubblici
Dove arriva l'innamorato
Che si è portato anche lui
Un amico
Si presentano
Poi ogni coppia
Per conto suo
E questo per quanto riguarda
Le ragazze da sposare
Le donne sposate
Hanno uno spazio
Hanno due spazi diversi
Uscire effettivamente
Più di rado
Molto in casa
Ma in casa non è che
Non è intrigente
Sia chiaro
Io qui parlo sempre
Delle novelle di Boccaccio
Ci sono altre fonti
Ma queste novelle
Sono qualche cosa
Che tutti possono andare a vedere
Sono scritte in italiano
Se Dio vuole
Nelle novelle di Boccaccio
Si impara che in casa
Vanno i parenti
I compari
Del marito
Importantissimi
E in generale
Gli amici del marito
Questi vanno
Vengono
Vanno in casa
Anche quando il marito non c'è
E le donne non è che hanno
Il loro quartiere
L'arem
Segregato
La casa è la casa
La gente va e viene
E poi si esce
Appunto
Nei giorni di festa
Dopodiché
Dice Boccaccio
Ci sono anche
Dei mariti
Che non vogliono
Lasciare uscire la moglie
Neanche nei giorni di festa
E ci sono
È evidente che ci sono
Così come è evidente
Da come ne parla Boccaccio
Che il loro è un comportamento
Che come dire
Nessuno le può obbligare
A lasciare uscire le moglie
Però la gente sparla
Quello lì
Esse
Dice Boccaccio
Stanno tutta la settimana rinchiuse
Si occupano
Della famiglia
Della casa
E il giorno di festa
Anche loro
Come tutti gli altri
Hanno voglia di divertirsi
E hanno voglia di divertirsi un po'
Di distrarsi
Di potere
Alcun
Di porto
Pigliare
Come vogliono
Le leggi
Sante
Perché la domenica
È giorno di festa
Di riposo
Di passatempo
Alla qualcosa fare
Niente
I gelosi
Consentono
Anzi
Proprio i giorni di festa
Che per le altre
Sono i giorni in cui
Ci si diverte
I mariti gelosi
Fanno ad esse
Tenendole più serrate
E più rinchiuse
Essere più miseri
E più dolenti
Dopodiché
Quindi
Cosa impariamo
Primo
C'era un sacco di mariti
I quali
Se la moglie voleva uscire
Le diceva
Perché vuoi uscire
No no
Tu non esci
Cosa vuoi andare a fare
Stai a casa
E contemporaneamente
Contemporaneamente
Impariamo
Che i vicini
Quei mariti lì
Li consideravano
Gente
Che non si fa così
Non bisogna far così
Poi una delle novelle
Del boccaccio
Mette appunto
In scena
Un marito
Particolarmente
Geloso
Non vuole neanche
Che la moglie
Si affaccia alla finestra
Poi ti vedono
Ovviamente
Andrà a finire
Come immaginate
È una novella
Del boccaccio
Il marito
Avrà quello
Che si merita
In quel caso
Abbiamo citato
Prima anche i fratelli
Certo
Certo che anche i fratelli
L'onore della famiglia
Riguarda tutti i maschi
Il cui onore
Può essere leso
Se le donne
Della famiglia
Si comportano male
Io una volta
Ho trovato un documento
Che mi ha impressionato
Profondamente
Siamo
Più o meno
Al tempo del boccaccio
Siamo in Valle d'Aosta
Quindi una società
Contadina
Montanara
Nel 1347
I signori di un villaggio
Della Valle d'Aosta
I signori di Aviz
Devono giudicare
Un caso di omicidio
E sono così imbarazzati
Che chiamano
Molti altri nobili
Della Valle d'Aosta
Per consigliarli
E aiutarli
A capire
Come giudicare
Questo caso
Vengono giudicati
Per omicidio
Dei giovani
Fratelli
Contadini
Contadini ricchi
Hanno un sacco di bestie
Che hanno ammazzato
La sorella
Com'è andata
Questa cosa
Li interrogano
Di nuovo
Dopo averli torturati
Un po'
E loro
Sempre rispondono
La stessa versione
Nostra sorella
Si chiamava Babel
Questa ragazza
Siamo nel villaggio
Di Sarella
Sopra
Sopra Aviz
Un po' a Monte
D'Aosta
Nostra sorella
Rubava
E nessuno
Riusciva
A impedirglielo
Rubava
E è stata scoperta
Più volte
E a un certo punto
I signori
Le hanno tagliato
Un'orecchia
Perché le pene
Per il furto
Le pene corporali
Alla recidiva
Erano abituali
E allora
A un certo punto
C'è stato un consiglio
Di famiglia
Con papà
Mamma
E noi fratelli
E ci siamo detti
Cosa facciamo
Non si può continuare così
Perché questa qui
Ci disonora
Tutti
E alla fine
Papà ha deciso
La mandiamo via
La mandiamo in un altro paese
Che vada a vivere altrove
Portatela via
E i fratelli
E i fratelli partono
E i fratelli partono con la sorella
Salgono su verso il gran San Bernardo
Per mandarla via
Lontano
E poi dicono
E salendo
Ci dicevamo fra noi
Ma cosa serve
Questa qui torna
Torna
Ruberà di nuovo
E i signori
La metteranno a morte
E noi saremo disonorati
Perciò
Salendo
Verso il gran San Bernardo
Appena sotto
Ci sono dei laghetti
Si sono fermati lì
Si sono guardati
L'hanno affogata nel laghetto
E poi sono tornati giù
E la cosa è stata scoperta
I signori li hanno arrestati
E loro hanno detto
Credevamo di far bene
E i signori
Non sanno come fare
Perché lo capiscono
Anche loro
Come hanno ragionato
Questi qua
E chiedono consiglio
E alla fine
La sentenza è
Una multa
Da levarvi la pelle
Però
Basta
Non di più
Perché?
Perché è chiaro
Che credevate
Di far bene
Quindi finisce così
Avranno venduto
Tutte le vacche
Per pagare la multa
Però comunque
Hanno operato
Dentro una logica
Che si può capire
Naturalmente
Al tempo stesso
I fratelli
Sono quelli
Che se la moglie
E se la sorella
E' sposata
E il matrimonio
E' andato male
E il marito
E' uno che la picchia
Più del giusto
Ed è un
La tratta male
Su questo
Le novelle
Del boccaccio
Sono chiarissime
Dopo un po'
I fratelli
E della moglie
Arrivano dal marito
E diranno
Oh
Com'è
Questa storia
Come ti permetti
Di trattare così
Nostra sorella
Dopodiché
Le novelle del boccaccio
Offrono anche
Uno squarcio
Su una conseguenza
Che secondo me
Io credo
Che sia molto importante
Per capire
Quel mondo
Una conseguenza
Di questo modo
Di vivere
Per cui capite
Le donne stanno
Molto a casa
Gli uomini
Stanno molto fuori
E quindi
Vivono molto
Donne fra donne
E uomini
Fra uomini
Nell'intimità
Della casa
Abbiamo detto
In casa
La gente
Va e viene
Ma poi
Quando si tratta
Dell'intimità
Vera
Una donna
Non si fa
Servire
Da uomini
Ovviamente
Boccaccio
Ha sempre in mente
Gente di una classe
Sociale
Agiata
Che ha dei servitori
Ma non dimentichiamoci
Che fino
Alla seconda guerra mondiale
Chiunque avesse
Un minimo
Di mezzi
Aveva dei domestici
In casa
Naturalmente
E le donne
Vengono servite
Da donne
Com'è che Boccaccio
Viene a parlarci
Di questo
È una cosa così ovvia
Per il suo mondo
Che non ci sarebbe
Nessun motivo
Di dircelo
Invece
Ce lo dice
Perché è arrivata
La peste
E quando è arrivata
Il mondo
È andato
A gambe
All'aria
Han cominciato
A succedere
Cose
Che non si erano
Mai viste
Quando è arrivata
La peste
Dice Boccaccio
È nato
Un uso
Quasi
Davanti
Mai
Non udito
Cioè che le donne
Siccome ormai
C'era difficoltà
Ad avere dei domestici
Accettavano
Di farsi servire
Anche da uomini
Voi capite
In tutto il mondo
Del passato
Farsi servire
Voleva dire
Vestirsi
Spogliarsi
Farsi aiutare
In tutte le cose
Fisiche
E mai si era visto
Che una donna
Avesse in camera sua
A servirla
Un maschio
Quando c'è stata
La peste
Questo è successo
E ogni donna
Apriva
Ai suoi servitori
Maschi
Senza alcuna
Vergogna
Ogni parte
Del corpo
Non altrimenti
Che a una femmina
Avrebbe
Fatto
Dopodiché
La cosa più interessante
È che
Ci sono
Degli ambiti
Della vita collettiva
Che riguardano
Solo le donne
E da cui gli uomini
Sono tagliati fuori
Quella più ovvia
Ne parleremo
Un po' più avanti
Ovviamente
È la gravidanza
Il parto
L'allattamento
Ma io prima
Vorrei parlare
Vorrei parlarvi
Di una cosa
Un po' meno ovvia
Di questa
E cioè
Che si dava
Per scontato
Che dovessero
Occuparsi
Solo
Le donne
Dell'assistenza
Ai malati
Del conforto
Ai moribondi
E della cura
Dei morti
Occuparsi
Di tutto
Quello
Che riguarda
La malattia
E poi
La morte
Il lutto
Occuparsi
Del corpo
Prepararlo
Per la sepoltura
Tutti
Questi
Ambiti
Spettavano
Alle donne
Per cui si dava
Per scontato
Che quando uno
È malato
Intorno al letto
Ha le donne
Le donne
Di famiglia
Le vicine
E anche qui
Dice Boccaccio
Con la peste
È andato tutto
Per aria
Senza
Aver
Molte
Donne
E d'attorno
Morivan
Le genti
Il mondo
Alla rovescia
Perché quando
Tu stai morendo
Sai
Che intorno
Al tuo letto
Ci saranno
Delle donne
Che ti assistono
Ti confortano
Ti stanno vicine
E la cosa più interessante
Perché è più totalitaria
Proprio la separazione
Uomini da una parte
Donne dall'altra
E quando il morto
È morto
Quando il morto
C'è tutta una serie
Di riti
E di occasioni
Anche sociali
Come noi oggi
C'è il funerale
La visita
La firma
Ecco anche loro
Hanno le loro
Ritualità
Intorno al morto
E cosa succede
Parto anche qui
Da una novella
Di Boccaccio
La novella
Di Girolamo
E Salvestra
Girolamo
Era innamoratissimo
Di Salvestra
Poi ha dovuto partire
Salvestra
Si è sposata
Con un altro
Girolamo torna
Si introduce
In casa sua
Scopre che davvero
Lei è sposata
Con un altro
Muore
Salvestra
E suo marito
Si svegliano
Trovano il morto
In casa
E lo portano fuori
Di nascosto
Il morto viene trovato
E viene portato
In chiesa
E portato il morto
Arrivano lì
La madre
Con molte altre donne
Parenti
E vicine
E sopra lui
Cominciarono
Dirottamente
A piangere
E a dolersi
Secondo
L'usanza nostra
Qui verrà in mente
A molti
L'immagine
Che noi abbiamo
Nella testa
Delle prefiche
Nella società
Mediterranea
Le donne vestite
Di nero
Che piangono
Sul morto
Nella Firenze
Del trecento
È una cosa ovvia
È l'usanza nostra
Certo che quando c'è il morto
Arrivano tutte le donne
A piangere
Il marito di
Ma non è questo il punto
Non è solo questo
Il marito di Salvestra
È un po' preoccupato
Che qualcuno
Faccio il collegamento
Tra questo morto
E casa loro
E quindi dice
Guarda dovremmo andare
A dare un'occhiata
A quello che sta succedendo
In chiesa
E quindi dice
Alla moglie
Me
Non dico traduco
Ma insomma
Semplifico un po'
In italiano
Più contemporaneo
Mettiti un po'
Un lembo
Del mantello
In testa
Perché non c'è
L'obbligo del velo
È ovvio
Ma una donna
Per bene
Qualcosa in testa
Se lo mette
Quando esce in strada
Cosa che rimarrà vera
Fino all'inizio del novecento
Perlomeno
Sia chiaro
Senza cappello
E va in chiesa
E mettiti tra le donne
E sta un po'
A sentire
Cosa si dice
Di questo fatto
E io farò
Il simigliante
Cioè farò la stessa cosa
Fra gli uomini
Dopodiché
Si capisce subito
Che appunto
Salvestra va in chiesa
Dentro
Perché le donne
Sono dentro
E il marito
Sta fuori
Perché gli uomini
Stanno fuori
Non vanno
Dentro
Poi naturalmente
Nella novella
È una di quelle
Un po'
Tragiche
Le novelle di Boccaccio
Lo sapete
Certe volte
Finiscono bene
Finiscono male
Questa è una di quelle
Che finiscono male
Salvestra entra in chiesa
Vede
L'ex amante
Morto
Muore anche lei
E tutte le donne
Dentro
Piangono
Ancora di più
Finché
Sparsesi
Fuor
Della chiesa
Tra gli uomini
La novella
Cioè la notizia
Gli uomini
Sono tutti fuori
È un'abitudine
No no
È un obbligo
Qui c'è un caso
Curioso
Vabbè naturalmente
Poi ecco scusate
No ancora questo
Così siamo più precisi
In chiesa
Certo
Ma è quando il morto
È in casa
C'è la veglia funebre
In casa
Anche lì
Boccaccio lo dice
Nell'introduzione
Del Decameron
L'usanza nostra
È che quando c'è
Il morto in casa
Le donne
Parenti
E vicine
Si radunano
In casa
A piangere
E d'altra parte
Dinanzi
Alla casa
Del morto
Si radunano
I vicini
I conoscenti
Maschi
Questa cosa
È talmente
Ferrea
Che
Ben prima di Boccaccio
L'ha raccontata
Anche Dante
Dante
L'ha raccontata
Perché è successo a lui
Lo racconta
Nella vita nuova
Sapete
Vita nuova
È una specie di romanzo
Che però racconta
Le vicende
Effettive
Della conoscenza
Di Dante
Con Beatrice
E così via
Ora
Il 31 dicembre
Del 1289
È morto
Il papà
Di Beatrice
Folco Portinari
E Dante
Dice
E si sa
Che l'usanza
Della nostra città
E che in questi casi tristi
C'è il morto
Ci si raduna
Donne con donne
E uomini
Con uomini
Perciò
Essendo morto
Folco Portinari
Solo le donne
Parenti
Vicine
Amiche
Curiose
Solo le donne
Possono entrare in casa
Dove c'è il morto
Gli uomini
Devono stare fuori
Dante
Decide di andare
Arriva
E deve stare fuori
E comincia a pensare
Povera Beatrice
Chissà come soffre
E pensando
A Beatrice
Chissà come soffre
Gli viene da piangere
Escono le donne
Che erano state a piangere
Dentro
Con Beatrice
Escono
Lo vedono
Dico
Guarda quello che piange
Ma neanche fosse stato dentro con noi
E una gli fa
Lascia piangere noi
Cosa c'entri tu?
Tu sei un uomo
Fai la tua parte
E noi facciamo la nostra
E poi ci sono ancora altre situazioni
Che a noi
Non verrebbe da pensarci
Altre situazioni in cui
Uomini e donne
Non stanno insieme
Dunque
In generale
Devo dire
Mentre quando voi vedete
Un film
O una serie
Che presenta
Per esempio
Un banchetto
Nel Medioevo
Vedete ovviamente
Uomini e donne
Sedute agli stessi tavoli
Non che fosse impossibile
Tutt'altro
Ma di sicuro
Era molto frequente
Che c'era
Il tavolo degli uomini
E il tavolo delle donne
Ma ancora meglio
Un'altra cosa
Che racconta Dante
Sempre nella vita nuova
Dante nella vita nuova
Racconta
Lui è innamoratissimo
Di Beatrice
È un amico
Che lo sa
Credendo
Dice Dante
Di farmi un grande piacere
Un giorno mi ha detto
Senti
Io sto andando
A casa di una donna
Che si è appena sposata
E vieni con me
Che sarai contento
Vanno
Arrivano a casa
Dove la sposa
Se siede
A tavola
Insieme a molte altre donne
È una casa ricca
Una sala tutta frescata
Dipinta
E c'è questa tavolata
Sono tutte donne
La sposa
E altre donne
È la casa del marito
È già avvenuto
Quello che nel Medioevo
È il momento
Cruciale
Del matrimonio
Voi non vi immaginerete
Mica che nel Medioevo
Si sposassero come noi
Andando in chiesa
Dal parroco
Ma nemmeno per idea
Non ci avrebbero pensato
Neanche lontanamente
Ci si sposava
Andando dal notaio
A firmare un contratto
E poi
Facendo vedere
A tutta la città
Che il marito
Andava
A casa del suocero
A prendere la moglie
E la portava
A casa propria
Ma questo è il matrimonio
Poi se ci tieni molto
Passando davanti alla parrocchia
Ti fai un segno di croce
Il parroco esce
Da una benedizione
Ma non ha alcuna importanza
E alcun rilievo alla cosa
Arrivi a casa del marito
E a casa del marito
Quella sera
La sposa
È a tavola
Con sole
Altre donne
E
E c'è anche Beatrice
Dopodiché
Il succo del racconto
È che Dante
Fa una figura penosa
Come al solito
Perché appena si accorge
Che c'è Beatrice
Comincia a balbettare
A arrossire
A dire stupidaggini
Tanto che l'amico
Deve prenderlo
Portarlo via
Perché lui ha perso
Completamente la testa
Ma al di là di questo
Che ci sono andati a fare
Dante e l'amico
Se voi guardate
Nelle storie della letteratura
Vi diranno
Di solito
Era un pranzo di nozze
Ma nemmeno per idea
Era l'ultima volta
Che la sposa
Che aveva vissuto
Fino a quel momento
Sempre insieme
Ad altre donne
Si trovava
Insieme
Ad altre donne
Prima di fare
Quel passo
Quella trasformazione
Decisiva
Della sua vita
Che consisteva
Nel cominciare
A vivere insieme
Con un uomo
Per l'ultima volta
Stava solo
Insieme ad altre donne
Le quali le avranno
Spiegato
Insegnato
Raccontato
Un momento di passaggio
E Dante e l'amico
Eravamo lì
Per servirle
Dice
Le donne
Pranzano
I gentiluomini
Presenti
Le servono
Due ruoli
Separati
Di nuovo
Dopodiché
Come dicevamo
La grande maggioranza
Delle donne
Si sposavano
Giovani
In molte epoche
Dico in molte epoche
Perché voi lo capite
Il Medioevo
Dura mille anni
Nessuna regola
Vale sempre
Però per il Medioevo
Che noi conosciamo meglio
Il basso Medioevo
I secoli
Dei nostri grandi
Scrittori medievali
In quel mondo lì
Le donne si sposavano
Giovanissime
Ovviamente
Perché sposarsi
A cosa serve?
A fare figli
Lo scopo
Dell'umanità
Stabilito da Dio
È crescere
E moltiplicarsi
Noi siamo qui
Per fare figli
E ogni uomo
Maschio
Desidera
Che il suo sangue
Il suo cognome
Il suo stemma
Continuino
E tutto questo
Dipende dalle donne
Quindi bisogna
Sposarle
E fargli fare figli
E quindi
Le donne
Si sposano
Giovani
Appena
Sono in grado
Di cominciare
Gli uomini
In genere
Si sposano
Molto dopo
L'uomo
Si sposa
Quando è sistemato
Ha una posizione
Tendenzialmente
Il papà
È morto
Ha ereditato
È in grado
Di mantenere
Una moglie
E di mantenere
Una famiglia
Tenetelo presente
Questo dislivello
Di età
Che c'è per lo più
Fra marito e moglie
Perché è importante
Per capire poi
Le dinamiche concrete
La maggioranza
Delle donne
Si sposano
Giovanissime
Con un uomo
Più anziano
E cominciano
A fare figli
E per quelle
Che sono fortunate
E non muoiono
Di parto
La vita
È una successione
Di imprese
Ogni volta
È un'impresa
Restare incinta
E portare a termine
La gravidanza
E partorire
Un bambino sano
E farlo crescere
E le donne
Che ci riescono
Sono ammirate
Coccolate
Certo
Quelle sfortunate
A cui i bambini
Muoiono
O che non riescono
A restare incinte
Cioè
Non stanno facendo
Quello per cui
Per cui sono al mondo
Dopodiché
Impressionante
Forse sto usando
Troppo la parola
Impressionante
Mi scuserete
È che io
Vi parlo delle cose
Che mi hanno più
Impressionato a me
Personalmente
Lavorando su questi testi
Su questi documenti
Su queste fonti
Cercando di conoscere
Questa gente
Le donne
Vivevano
Immerse
In questo mondo
In cui
Se non sei tu
È tua sorella
O la mamma
O la figlia
Che in quel momento
È incinta
È il bimbo piccolo
Che in quel momento
È allatta
Continuamente
Sei immersa
In questa dimensione
Tu
O le altre donne
Intorno a te
E questo
Si vede
Dalla frequenza
Con cui
Gli vengono
In mente
Alle donne
Queste immagini
E vi faccio
Un esempio
Vado a prendere
In una lezione
Che ho fatto
Tanti anni fa
Magari qualcuno
L'avrà già sentita
Mi scuso
Su Caterina da Siena
Santa Caterina da Siena
Quindi
Una ragazza
Che ha precisamente
Rifiutato
Questo tipo
Di destino
Prestabilito
Caterina da Siena
Muore
Vergine
A 33 anni
Lei
Non ha mai conosciuto
L'uomo
Il matrimonio
Il sesso
La gravidanza
Il parto
L'allattamento
Niente
Lei ha detto
Chiaramente
Io questa roba
Non la voglio
Io sono sposata
Con lui
La mamma
Di Caterina
Lapa
Quando nasce
Caterina
Sono due gemelline
In realtà
Poi una muore
Caterina vive
Quando nasce
Caterina
La mamma
Ha già partorito
22 figli
Di cui
In meno della metà
Sono ancora vivi
Dopodiché
Cosa succede
Caterina
Cresce
E quando ha
12 anni
La mamma
E le sorelle maggiori
Cominciano a dirle
Caterina
Ormai sei grandicella
E bisogna cominciare
A pensarci
La mamma
Comincia a insistere
Quali sono
Le cose
Su cui la mamma
Insiste
Lavati la faccia
Di più la faccia
Pettinati
Fatti bella
Devi impomatarti
I capelli
Strapparti i peli
Superflui
Dal viso
E dal collo
Perché devi essere
Carina
E ora
Ormai
Caterina
Non osa neanche
In quel
Caterina
Ha già deciso
Da bambina
Che il suo destino
Non sarà quello
Ha già avuto
Le visioni
Sentito le voci
Ha già capito
Che lei farà qualcosa
Di completamente diverso
Che vivrà
Che sposerà Gesù
Non un uomo
Però non osa ancora
Dirlo in casa
Però le altre donne
In casa capiscono
Che c'è qualcosa
Che non va
Caterina
Fa resistenza
Allora la mamma
Chiede aiuto
Alla sorella maggiore
Di Caterina
Buonaventura
Che è una donna
Sposata
Con figli
E Buonaventura
Spiega a Caterina
Guarda che non c'è
Niente di male
Sai
E così
Ci si sposa
Si fanno i figli
E Caterina
Per un po'
Ci crede
E accetta
Di entrare
In quella prospettiva
Poi il 10 agosto
Buonaventura
Muore di parto
E Caterina
Si convince
Che è colpa sua
Perché per un momento
Ha esitato
Si è lasciata convincere
Ha accettato
Questa prospettiva
Di
D'ora in poi
Non ci ricascherà più
Dopodiché
Caterina
Che quindi
Non conoscerà mai
Le esperienze
Normali
Per quasi tutte
Le altre donne
Della sua epoca
Nei suoi scritti
Ha scritto un sacco
Caterina
Ha scritto
Dettato
Un'infinità di lettere
Opere varie
Teologiche
Preghiere
Ecco nei suoi scritti
Caterina
Caterina a un certo punto
Descrive una visione
Che ha avuto
Caterina ha regolarmente
Dice delle visione
Dio
Dio le appare
Le parla
Sono momenti meravigliosi
Prova dentro
Una dolcezza
Indescrivibile
E c'è stato
Un periodo
In cui per un po'
Dio non veniva
E lei c'è stata male
Però poi quando Dio
E' tornato
Per lei è stato
Un momento
Meraviglioso
E dice
Caterina
E come quando
Le mamme
Come dire
Che allattano
Un bambinello
Che amano
Veramente molto
E per aumentare
Ancora il piacere
Gli fanno
Questo scherzo
Che gli fanno
Vedere il seno
E poi lo tengono
Lontano
E lui frigna
E la mamma
Gode immensamente
Quando poi
Se lo avvicina
Davvero al seno
E vede
L'immenso piacere
Con cui questo bambino
Comincia a succhiare
Così dice
Caterina
Ha fatto Dio
Con me
Mi ha tenuto
Lontano
Per un po'
E poi
Per avere ancora
Maggior piacere
Un altro esempio
L'epoca di Caterina
È quella in cui
Il papa sta ad Avignone
Sapete
Il papa è avignonese
In Italia
Sono tutti scocciati
Insistono
Col papa
Torna
Devi tornare a Roma
Il posto del papa
È a Roma
Caterina è impegnata
In prima linea
In questa battaglia
Perché il papa
Torni in Italia
Gli scrive
Continuamente
Al papa
Ad Avignone
Gregorio XI
Dicendo
Torna
Tenete conto
Che Caterina
Ha un'autorità
Internazionale
È una persona
Una santa
Viva
Conosciutissima
Una che parla
Con Dio
Quando arriva
Una sua lettera
È un evento
Sono lettere aperte
Pubbliche
Le conoscono tutti
Io non oso pensare
Che faccia faceva
Il papa ad Avignone
Quando gli dicevano
Guardi è arrivata
Un'altra lettera
Di Caterina
E Caterina
Scrive al papa
Dicendo
Torna in Italia
Il papa
Alla fine
Le dice
Ma guarda
Io tornerei anche
Ma un indovino
Mi ha predetto
Che se torno in Italia
Mi avvelenano
L'Italia
Era già allora
Nell'immaginario
Dell'Europa del Nord
Il paese
Degli intrighi
Delle porcherie
Dei veleni
Eccetera
Mi avvelenano
E Caterina
Gli risponde
Ma voi siete
Un ingenuo
Come un neonato
Questa cosa
Che vi hanno detto
E come le mamme
Quando vogliono
Svezzare
Il bambino
Perché è ora
Di smettere
Di allattarlo
A tre anni
Il bambino
Magari è ora
Di smettere
E le mamme
Si spalmano
Qualcosa di amaro
Sul capezzolo
Così il bambino
Accosta la bocca
Sente l'amaro
Si allontana
Non lo sa
Il bambino
Scemo
Che sotto l'amaro
C'è sempre il dolce
E così
Lei dice al papa
Tu sei come quel bambino
Ti fanno credere
Che venire in Italia
Sarà pericoloso
Tragico
Eccetera
Ora
Al di là del fatto
Che poi il papa
Si fa convincere
Torna a Roma
Muore
Ma
Al di là di questo
Quello che è interessante
È che Caterina
Le vengono naturali
Queste immagini
La mamma che allatta
La mamma che deve svezzare
È cresciuta
Assorbendo
Quelle immagini
Ovviamente
Anche in quelle dimensioni
Che a noi
Possono sembrare
Più tragiche
Quando parla
Sempre parlando
Al papa
Gli dice
So che avete
Nominato dei cardinali
Spero che siano
Un po' meglio
Di quelli
Dell'ultima volta
Perché basta
Con questi cardinali
E questi vescovi
Che fanno solo
Il loro interesse
Corrotti
Putri
Di schifosi
Basta
Perché questi
Un prelato
Che pensa solo
Al suo interesse
Non dà nessun frutto
Costui fa
Come la donna
Che partorisce
I figliuoli morti
E certo
Una donna
Che ha avuto
La sfortuna
Di partorisce
E il bimbo
Nasce morto
E per carità
Non è colpa sua
Però
Però di nuovo
Quello che volevo
Farvi vedere
È come appunto
Per una come Caterina
Che queste cose
Non le ha sperimentate
Lei
Questo mondo
Di immagini
Di riferimenti
Le vengono
Automaticamente
In testa
Perché quello
È l'universo
In cui cresce
Una bambina
Poi naturalmente
Ci sono anche
Casi estremi
Diversi
In un'altra lezione
Anche qui mi scuso
Con chi la conosce già
C'è una grande
Scrittrice francese
Di fine 300
Christine de Pizan
È un esempio
Di come una donna
Intelligentissima
Del Medioevo
Percepiva
Questa sua società
Piena di pregiudizi
E di limitazioni
Per le donne
Christine de Pizan
È una donna
Molto colta
Era la figlia
Di un medico
Di un medico importante
Medico del re di Francia
E lei racconta
Che lei
Ha letto tanti libri
Ha studiato molto
Perché suo papà
L'ha fatta studiare
Suo papà
Diceva
Anche le donne
Devono imparare
Devono istruirsi
La mamma
Non era d'accordo
Avrebbe voluto
Che lei stesse sempre
A filare
Perché una ragazza
Deve imparare
A fare la moglie
La padrona di casa
Invece il papà
Mi ha fatta studiare
Il che non toglie
Che poi
A 15 anni
L'hanno fatta sposare
E certo
Ovvio
L'hanno fatta sposare bene
Con un segretario
Del re di Francia
Un uomo che aveva
9 anni più di lei
Con cui è stata benissimo
Certo
Essere sposata
Vuol dire fare dei figli
Continuamente
Cristina nelle sue opere
Lo dice
Io in quel periodo lì
Non avevo tempo
Neanche per leggere
Se non ero incinta
Avevo il bambino al seno
E poi suo marito
Dopo dieci anni
Muore
Lei ha 25 anni
E vedova
Con tre figli piccoli
E in uno dei suoi libri
Racconta
In modo metaforico
Quello che ha provato
Quando si è trovata
Di colpo
Sola
Senza più
Suo marito
A dirigere la famiglia
Lei descrive
Questa situazione
Come un sogno
In cui era a bordo
Di una nave
Era la nave
Della sua famiglia
Che navigava
In modo prospero
E felice
Poi è arrivata la tempesta
E il pilota della nave
È stato scaraventato
In mare
E lei voleva gettarsi
Io volevo gettarmi
In mare anch'io
Nel sogno
Dice
Mi hanno trattenuta
Nella nave
Va alla deriva
E poi Cristina
Racconta
Sempre in questa cosa
Lei sta inventando
Chiaramente questo sogno
Che è un'immagine
Di come lei ha vissuto
Il trovarsi
Capofamiglia
All'improvviso
Mi è apparsa
La fortuna
La fortuna è una figura
Femminile
Che nell'immaginario
Medievale
Significa non soltanto
Come per noi
Vincere la lotteria
Significa
I cambiamenti
Improvvisi
Quelle cose
Che succedono
Nella vita
Che di colpo
Cambiano
No la tua vita
Dice la fortuna
È venuta
Da me
Mi ha maneggiata
Mi ha toccata
Io dormivo
Mi sono svegliata
Avevo perso
L'anello nuziale
E mi sentivo
Trasformata
È interessante
Vedere in che senso
Lei
Devo dirlo subito
Non rovino la suspense
No
Lei sogna
Che si è trasformata
In un uomo
E come lo descrive
Questo
È una donna
Che immagina
Cosa vorrebbe dire
Diventare un uomo
Mi sentì
Molto più leggera
Del solito
Io questa cosa
L'ho trovata bellissima
Perché è controintuitiva
Uno pensa
L'uomo è più grosso
Più pesante
No
La donna percepisce
Che l'uomo non ha
Questo peso
Della gravidanza
Dei bambini
Lei pensa
Che l'uomo
Si senta più leggero
Di lei
E il mio volto
Era cambiato
E indurito
E la mia voce
Si era fatta più profonda
E il corpo più forte
E snello
Mi ritrovai
Con un animo
Forte e ardito
Di cui mi sorprendevo
E capì
Di essere diventata
Un vero uomo
Questo è il modo
In cui lei racconta
Il fatto che
Rimasta vedova
Si è trovata
A dover dirigere
Senza un uomo
Al suo fianco
La famiglia
Dopodiché
Mi rendo conto
Che dicendo questo
Sembra che lei
Stia dentro in pieno
L'idea che comunque
L'uomo è più capito
Ma non è così
Perché Cristina
Ha una grande capacità
Di andare a sgonfiare
I luoghi comuni
Sulle differenze
Fra uomini e donne
Per esempio
Dice
Certo ci sono poche donne
Dotte
I dotti
Sono tutti uomini
Gli intellettuali
Ma è perché
Le bambine
Non vanno a scuola
Provate un po'
A mandarle a scuola
Allora vedreste
Ne saprebbero
Quanto gli uomini
Dopodiché
Dice
Ci sono anche
Alcuni casi
Di uomini
Dotti
Che hanno fatto
Studiare
Le loro figlie
Uno
Non faccio per vantarmi
Mio papà
Infatti
Ma poi
Lei cita anche
Un altro esempio
C'è un professore
Di giurisprudenza
Dall'università
Di Bologna
Tutti lo conoscono
Quello lì
Aveva fatto studiare
Sua figlia
E la figlia
Era così brava
Che lo sostituiva
A lezione
E il problema
Dice Cristina
Quindi non è
Neanche con gli uomini
Istruiti
Gli uomini istruiti
Lo capiscono
Che anche le donne
Potrebbero arrivarci
Il problema
Sono gli uomini
Ignoranti
Che non sopporterebbero
Di trovarsi davanti
A donne
Che ne sanno
Più di loro
Dopodiché
Cristina
E anche lei
Una donna
Anche lei
È stata plasmata
Dall'esperienza
Della gravidanza
Della maternità
Cristina è una scrittrice
Ha prodotto
Un sacco di libri
Come racconta
Il momento
In cui
È diventata scrittrice
Dice
In realtà
È la natura
Che mi ha spinto
In quella direzione
Dovevo farlo
Ma lei
Voi capite
Lo racconta sempre
Lei appartiene
A questa cultura
Medievale
Che noi incontriamo
Anche in Dante
E che a noi
E che a noi non piace più tanto
Tutte queste metafore
Queste raffigurazioni
La fortuna
La natura
Tutte donne
Fra l'altro
E dice
La natura
Mi è apparsa
E mi ha detto
Che il mio destino
Era di scrivere
Dei libri
E mi ha detto
All'epoca
In cui portavi
I bambini
Nel ventre
Sentivi
Grandi dolori
Al momento
Di partorire
Ora io voglio
Che da te
Nascano
Dei nuovi libri
Che conserveranno
Il tuo ricordo
Nel mondo
Nei tempi a venire
E per sempre
E partorirai
Nella gioia
Grazie alla tua
Intelligenza
Qui chiaramente
Contrappone
Al biblico
Partorirai
Nel dolore
Dopodiché
Non è che dica
Che fare libri
È tutto un divertimento
E no no
Fare libri
È una fatica
Proprio come fare
Un bambino
Però
Dice Cristina
Che lo sa
Non è come Caterina
Che l'ha soltanto
Respirato in casa
Cristina lo sa
Tu partorisci
È una fatica
È un dolore
Però poi
Appena senti
Il bambino
Che strilla
Ti dimentichi
Tutto
E allo stesso modo
Le dice la natura
Fare dei libri
Sarà faticoso
Penoso
Ma appena
Sentirai
Il brusio
Che si farà
Sui tuoi libri
Ti dimenticherai
Tutta quella fatica
E tutto quel dolore
Quindi insomma
Anche una donna
Eccezionale
Che ha chiarissimo
Il fatto
Che le donne
Sono discriminate
Per motivi assurdi
E che hanno
Tutte le stesse potenzialità
Degli uomini
Però
Quello che volevo
Sottolineare adesso
Nello specifico
È che anche per lei
Questo universo
Della gravidanza
E del parto
È comunque
Una dimensione
Fortemente presente
Nel suo
Nel suo modo
Di vedere la vita
Ora
Lo sto facendo
Molto lunga
Molti di voi
So che devono andare
A cena
Dopo la conferenza
Qualche ristoratore
Mi ha pregato
Di finire presto
Ancora un pochino
Avrei ancora
Un sacco di roba
Ma insomma
Cerchiamo di abbreviare
Allora
Noto che non dite
No no
Cercherò di abbreviare
No va bene
Va bene
Non la farò
Troppo lunga
Volevo ancora dire questo
Ho insistito finora
Sul fatto che esistono
Chiaramente sfere
Separate
Gli uomini
Fanno certe cose
Le donne certe altre
E fin qui
Solo che naturalmente
La sfera riservata
Alle donne
È quella
Che è dettata
Dalla loro natura stessa
Sono solo loro
Che possono restare incinte
E partorire
E allattare
È la natura
Che gli fa fare questo
Gli uomini
Fanno un sacco
Di altre cose
E non è la natura
Che li obbliga
Sono loro
Che se le sono inventate
La politica
La guerra
Il governo
Gli affari
E quindi capite
È molto facile
Per gli uomini
Convincersi
Che non è solo
Che siamo diversi
Ma è che certe cose
Le facciamo noi uomini
Perché le donne
Non sarebbero capaci
Chiaro che si convincono
Di questo
Intendiamoci
Non è che sia
Una prerogativa
Del medioevo
Andate a leggere
Cosa diceva
Aristotele
Delle donne
O cosa dicevano
Gli scienziati
Dell'ottocento
È una roba
Di lunghissima durata
Ma certamente
Anche nel medioevo
Se tu ponevi a chiunque
La domanda
Ma l'uomo è superiore
Alla donna
E la risposta era
Ma certo che sì
È una cosa
Evidente
Va da sé
Anche i più intelligenti
Ci cascavano
Torniamo a Dante
Dante
Nel De vulgari eloquenzia
Nel suo trattato
Sulla lingua
Si pone la domanda
Su chi sia
Il primo essere umano
Che ha parlato
Chiaro che
La lingua
Per Dante
È ciò che distingue
L'essere umano
Dagli animali
E anche dagli angeli
I quali non parlano
Neanche loro
Secondo lui
Solo gli esseri umani
Parlano
È un dono di Dio
Straordinario
Dopodiché
Problema
Chi è il primo essere umano
Che ha parlato
E come si fa
A rispondere a questa domanda
Vai a leggere la Genesi
Naturalmente
Nella Bibbia
E nella Bibbia
Ops
La prima che parla
È Eva
La prima menzione
Nel Genesi
Di un essere umano
Che parla
È Eva
Col serpente
Ma Dante
Dice
Non è ragionevole
Pensare che sia stata
La donna
A parlare per prima
Perché è un tale dono
Di Dio
Il linguaggio
E quindi
Non avrebbe senso
Che Dio
L'avesse dato
Alla donna
Prima che all'uomo
Deve aver parlato
Prima Adamo
Questo per dirvi
Come anche uno
Molto intelligente
Operava
All'interno
Di queste coordinate
Non riusciva
A venirne fuori
Notate che Dante
È lo stesso
Che racconta
Di quando ha visto
Beatrice
La prima volta
E ha passato
Tutto il resto
Della vita
A adorare
Beatrice
Questa Angela
Giovanissima
Che non pareva
Figlia d'uomo mortale
Ma di Dio
Eccetera
Questa gentilissima
Questa mirabile
Donna
Che una volta
Si è degnata
Di salutarmi
Io credo
Che forse
Alla fine
Quello che dobbiamo dire
È che non è
Che dobbiamo pretendere
Dalla gente
Del passato
Troppa coerenza
Nella visione
Del mondo
E che un conto
È quando si ripetono
Luoghi comuni
In termini generali
E un conto
È quando poi
Si tratta
Della tua esperienza
Personale
Certo che
I luoghi comuni
Generali
Essendo luoghi comuni
Giravano
Tutti li ripetevano
Le stesse banalità
Boccaccio
Lo fa dire
Anche alle donne
Torniamo al prologo
Del Decameron
Avete presente
C'è la peste
Si trovano
Sette
Ragazze
Sono ricche
Di buona famiglia
Fanno quello che vogliono
E si dicono
Dai andiamocene in campagna
Dai andiamo tutte in campagna
E poi una dice
Momento però
Siamo tutte femmine
Lo sapete tutti
Che le femmine
Insieme
Non riescono a cavarsela
Che senza un uomo
Che gli dia una mano
Non si arriva da nessuna parte
Noi siamo mobili
Riottose
Sospettose
Pusillanime
E paurose
Perciò
Se non ci prendiamo un uomo
Non ce la facciamo mica
A cavarcela
Cerchiamo degli uomini
Che vengano con noi
Naturalmente in chiesa
In quel momento
Entrano tre bei ragazzi
Di loro conoscenza
E è subito fatto l'affare
Questi luoghi comuni
Giravano
Certo che sì
Ce l'aveva in testa
Anche Caterina da Siena
Caterina da Siena
Che avete capito
Che tipo è
E che scriveva lettere
Al papa
Sgridandolo
E scriveva lettere
Anche ai re
Alle regine
Sgridando anche loro
A un certo punto
Scrive alla regina
Di Napoli
Caterina
Il papa
È tornato in Italia
È morto
Ne hanno fatto un altro
Che ha detto
Io resto a Roma
Poi i cardinali
Si sono pentiti
Han detto
Ci siamo sbagliati
Ne fanno un altro
Che torna da Vignone
Ci sono due papi
Uno contro l'altro
La regina di Napoli
All'inizio sosteneva
Il papa giusto
Quello che sta a Roma
Caterina è tutta
Per il papa di Roma
Poi le arriva
La notizia a Caterina
Che la regina di Napoli
Ha cambiato idea
Caterina scrive
Alla regina di Napoli
Ho trovato
Nella persona vostra
Poca verità
Non condizione
D'uomo
Con cuore virile
Ma di femmina
Senza nessuna
Fermezza
O stabilità
Siccome femmina
Che si volge
Come foglia
Al vento
Capite come sono forti
Queste cose
Ti viene automatico
Dirlo
Poi se ti chiedessero
Di ragionare
Su queste cose
Magari
Dessero
Sì no
Però invece così
Banalità
No
Ecco
C'è giusto
Christine de Pisan
Che si ribella
Contro queste banalità
Dicendo
Ma basta
Ma perché
Continuamente
Devo sentir dire
Che le donne
Chiacchierano
E basta
Che non sono capaci
Di fare niente
Basta
Con questa storia
Però la maggior parte
Della gente
E questo è un avvertimento
Anche per noi di oggi
Le cose
Che banalmente
Senti sempre
Dire in giro
Automaticamente
Finisci per dirle
Anche tu
Senza ragionarci
Più di tanto
Oh
Io vorrei finire
Però non senza
Dirvi ancora
Qualcosina
Su questo
Che
Io finora
Vi ho detto delle cose
Bene
Alcune sono caratteristiche
Della nostra società
Del basso medioevo
I riti
Intorno ai morti
Per esempio
Queste cose qua
Ma più in generale
La disuguaglianza
Tra maschi
E femmine
È un ambito
In cui il medioevo
Non è che abbia inventato
Chissà cosa
L'ha ereditato
Dall'antichità
E l'ha trasmesso
Al mondo moderno
Nel medioevo
Le donne
Se non erano
Regine
Appunto
O contesse
Non governavano
Non partecipavano
Ai consigli comunali
Agli uffici
E così via
Certo
Non potevano essere
Giudici
Certo
Perché
Ma perché sta scritto
Nel diritto romano
Non l'hanno mica
Inventato nel medioevo
Leggevano il corpus
Juris civilis
Ul piano
Grande giurista romano
Le donne
Sono escluse
Da tutti gli uffici
Politici
E pubblici
E perciò
Non possono essere
Giudici
Né essere elette
C'è scritto
Nel diritto romano
Cosa vuoi andare
A discutere
Però
Mentre nel mondo romano
Effettivamente
Di donne
Dentro all'impero
Dico
Fuori qualche esempio
C'è
Ma dentro all'impero romano
Di donne che hanno governato
O sentenziato
In tribunale
Non ce n'è davvero
La minima traccia
Nel medioevo
Qualcuna c'è
Matilde di Canossa
De Leonora
D'Aquitania
Contesse regine
Certo per carità
Però donne
Allora il medioevo
È un'epoca di teologi
E di giuristi
Abituati a ragionare
In modo chiaro
E limpido
Sulle cose
I quali dicono
La donna
Non può
Governare
Non può giudicare
È un bellissimo principio
Ma noi abbiamo visto
Delle donne
Che invece
Governavano
E giudicavano
Erano solo due o tre
Chi se ne frega
Però
A livello di principio
Le abbiamo viste
E allora
Uguccione da Pisa
Dodicesimo secolo
Certo che il diritto romano
Dice che la donna
Non può comandare
Non può giudicare
Ma se una donna
Si trova a occupare
Una posizione tale
Per cui invece
È chiamata a farlo
Allora può farlo
Ragazzi mi dispiace
Ma non si può
Che dire questo
Alternativa
Il papa può autorizzarla
E se il papa
L'autorizza
Non c'è diritto romano
Che conti
C'è stato un esempio
Certo che c'è stato
Eleonora d'Aquitania
Ex regina
Di Francia
D'Inghilterra
Ma poi comunque
Duchessa di Aquitania
Governna il suo territorio
È stata chiamata
Un giorno
A pronunciare
Non in quanto
Duchessa di Aquitania
È stata chiamata
A un arbitrato
A giudicare
In una controversia
Fra
Frati ospedalieri
E frati cistercensi
In un altro luogo
Non dove comandava lei
Le hanno chiesto
Fai tu da arbitro
Lei ha giudicato
Ha dato ragione
Ai cistercensi
Gli ospedalieri
A quel punto
Si sono opposti
Dicendo
Ma è una donna
La sentenza di una donna
Non vale
La cosa è arrivata
A papa Innocenzo III
E papa Innocenzo III
Con una decretale
Dice
È vero
Che secondo il diritto romano
Le donne sono escluse
Dagli uffici pubblici
Ma in Francia
Mi risulta
Che è abituale
Che invece
Le donne
Di condizione elevata
Quando sono al potere
Giudicano
E quindi
La consuetudine
Che ha valore
Di legge
Dice
Che
In quei casi
Le donne
Possono governare
E possono giudicare
E quindi
Qui siamo di fronte
Capite
Adesso cercherò
Di finire davvero
A un momento
In cui la riflessione
Medievale
Porta a andare
Oltre
A una
Visione
Estremamente
Semplicistica
Ereditata
Invece
Dal diritto romano
Un altro ambito
La dimensione medica
Il corpo
Il sesso
In tutto questo
Ovviamente
I medici medievali
Anche loro
Sono debitori
Dell'antichità
Anche loro
Leggono
I libri antichi
E ci credono
Ci mancherebbe
L'antichità
Figuriamoci
E quindi
Uno trova anche
Nel medioevo
Trattati
Che parlano
Di
Che ne so
Il sangue mestruale
Per esempio
È una cosa tremenda
Impedisce al grano
Di germinare
Fa inacidire
Il mosto
Al suo contatto
L'erba muore
Le piante
Perdono i frutti
Il ferro
Arrugginisce
Superstizioni
Medievali
Dice uno
Peccato
Che loro
Tutto questo
Lo leggevano
In Plinio
Il giovane
Cioè
Nel principale
Scienziato
Dell'antichità
Romana
Però
Poi
Nel medioevo
A un certo punto
Cominciano
A esserci
Dei medici
Che fanno
L'anatomia
Dei cadaveri
Che fanno
L'anatomia
Dei cadaveri
Che vanno a vedere
L'utero
Come è fatto
Quanto è grande
Come funziona
Poi certo
Il progresso
Scientifico
Non ha sempre
Una faccia simpatica
Quando uno
Legge i rapporti
Di dissezione
Dei cadaveri
Di un grande medico
Dell'inizio del 300
Contemporaneo
Di Dante
Mondino
Dell'Iuzzi
La donna
Che ho anatomizzato
L'anno scorso
Cioè
Nel 1314
A gennaio
Aveva
Un utero
Grande
Il doppio
Di quella
Che ho anatomizzato
Lo stesso anno
A marzo
Mentre l'utero
Della scrofa
Che ho anatomizzato
Nel 1316
Era cento volte
Più grande
Di quello
Che ho mai visto
In una femmina
Di umano
E questi
Sono gli scienziati
Questo è il linguaggio
Degli scienziati
Certo che può non essere
Però
Il medioevo
Fa anche questo
È possibile
Anatomizzare i cadaveri
Chiedono al papa
È lecito
Sì è lecito
Perché siamo qua
Per conoscere
E questa cultura
Dei medici
La chiesa
La rispetta
E la chiesa
Interessa
I teologi
Perché i teologi
Vogliono sapere
Cosa bisogna dire
Alla gente
Quali comportamenti
Sono legittimi
E quali sono proibiti
La masturbazione
Si può fare
Femminile
È un peccato grave
Alberto Magno
Grande teologo
Del 200
Scrive
La masturbazione
Femminile
Ed è chiaro
Che ha parlato
Con i medici
E i medici
Gli hanno detto
Eh ma capisci
Hai verso i 14 anni
La giovane donna
Comincia a desiderare
Il coito
Però il corpo femminile
È freddo
Quindi in assenza
Di un uomo
Che la riscaldi
Da sola
Non riesce
A raggiungere
Il piacere
E quindi si aiuta
E perciò
Certe ragazze
Anche se non hanno
Un partner
Si immaginano
Il coito
E fanno delle cose
Cito
E traduco dal latino
E fanno delle cose
Con le dita
O altri strumenti
Finché le loro ansie
Non sono temperate
E allora
Se i medici
Dicono
Che la natura
Spinge in quella direzione
Non può essere
Un peccato grave
Così come
Se i medici
Dicono
Che senza
Il piacere femminile
Non si concepiscono
Figli
E su questo
Ve lo risparmio
Ci sarebbe tutto
Ma comunque
È un grande dibattito
La donna serve
A qualcosa
Per fare i figli
O è soltanto
Il vaso
Dentro cui l'uomo
Impianta
Il figlio
Aristotele diceva
È soltanto il vaso
L'uomo mette tutto
Altri discutono
Nel medioevo
Sempre di più
Si discute
Alla fine
La maggioranza
Arriva a dire
No no
Ci vuole un contributo
Di entrambi
Ma il piacere
Cosa c'entra
Con il sesso
Se Dio ci ha messo
Il piacere
Perché il piacere
Ci vuole
Ma infatti
L'uomo
Prova piacere
Nel momento
Del coito
E se l'uomo
Non arriva al piacere
Non si fa niente
Ma se sia l'uomo
Sia la donna
Collaborano
A fare il figlio
Allora anche per la donna
Ci vorrà il piacere
È certo
Dicono i medici
E i teologi concordi
È certo
Senza il piacere
Della donna
Il figlio
Non può essere concepito
Lasciamo stare
Il fatto che noi
Sappiamo che non è così
Quello che ci interessa
È il tipo di ragionamento
Che fanno loro
E allora
Il piacere
Sessuale
Della donna
È necessario
Per avere figli
Dopodiché
Ci sono teologi
Che vanno anche oltre
Dicono
Al di là
Dell'avere figli
Ma nel sesso
Il piacere
Ci è stato messo
Così per sbaglio
O è una componente
Fondamentale
No
Dicono i teologi
Ovviamente
È una componente
Fondamentale
Quindi
Di nuovo
Uguccione da Pisa
XII secolo
Teorico del diritto
Canonico
È lecito
Fare sesso
Senza l'intenzione
Di fare bambini
Ma solo
Per dare piacere
Alla moglie
Per cui l'uomo
Non
Eiacula
Ma fa sesso
Esclusivamente
Finché la donna
Non è arrivata
Al piacere
Sì
Dice Uguccione da Pisa
Siccome il piacere
È stato messo lì
Come componente
Indispensabile
È lecito farlo
E tu
Uomo
Hai diritto
Di fare sesso
Con la tua donna
Portarla al piacere
Tu non
Scusate
Mi esprimo rozzamente
Lui parlava latino
Ma comunque
Il senso è questo
Tu non vieni
Non fai nessun peccato
Va bene così
E
E lo vedete
Che mondo complicato è
Dopodiché
È un mondo
In cui sono tutti d'accordo
Che
Il dovere
Coniugale
È un obbligo
Di legge
Nel senso che
La moglie
Non può rifiutarsi
È certo
Ed è anche
Un obbligo
Di legge
Nel senso che
Anche il marito
Non può rifiutarsi
È certo
Ovvio che
Il marito
Non può rifiutarsi
Se il marito
Rifiuta
Di fare sesso
Con la moglie
È un motivo
Di annullamento
Del matrimonio
La moglie
Gli fa causa
Allora
Qui ho abbreviato
Moltissimo
Una cosa
Che era più complessa
E ve ne siete accorti
Chiaramente
Ma è ora di finirla
Era semplicemente
Per dire
Che questo
È un tentativo
Di farvi vedere
Alcuni pezzi
Di come
Poteva funzionare
Una società
In cui
Tutti
Davano
Per scontato
Che
Se la domanda
È banalmente
L'uomo
È superiore
Alla donna
Ma certo
Che l'uomo
È superiore
Alla donna
Avrebbero risposto
Ma noi
Non capiremmo
Niente
Di chi erano
Se pensassimo
Che questo
Vuol dire
Che la donna
Semplicemente
Non c'era
Era invisibile
Non aveva
Considerazione
Né diritti
Le cose
Ed una di quelle
Conclusioni
Che purtroppo
Vanno bene
Per qualunque
Lezione di storia
Sono sempre
Un po' più
Complicate
Di così
Grazie
Grazie a tutti